we're go for launch everyone ready so
all yours take us out so it Curren Steve
all right Nick kurus yeah we going
Icarus is a war mine a war mind solar
collector on Mercury again the level
designers where do they come up this is
a really fascinating story about where
they come up with their inspiration but
they were they were fascinated by a real
world technology these power towers
these heliostat sort of thermal like
collectors that there exists on earth
they heat molten salt up to like 100
like 1500 degrees it's crazy so what
better place to collect solar energy
than mercury and certainly closer it's
well it's probably but but they yeah and
they put it in it like a call pit
basically and put all the arrays of
mirrors around the planet this data
collector it works amazing now this is
the first human installation that we've
seen on Mercury when I think about the
lighthouse or when I think about some of
the different crucible maps that you've
set there it's usually vex in nature but
this is you know wore mine similar to
rescue tanned that Golden Age tech is
coming more into play here so let the
games begin this is round two of
supremacy and as the match plays out
talk to us a little bit about how the
environment is unpacking the gameplay
looks like we've got our first our first
blood right there this one's a little
bit tighter than floating gardens is
this a symmetrical map uh this is a
radial map a radial network like you say
round eye round nature no it's a radio
map uh yeah it's the interiors it's a
lot like nominally but the exteriors are
much more open again this gorgeous sky
box at the artists have created must be
a warm eyes thing I mean anomaly is also
a circular map so the warm items yeah
they think in a circular fashion all
right picking up those crests
putting points on the board yeah running
the table sliding into the crest you get
style points for that no you don't but
you should but you see sure feel cool
doing it like Santa so that was great
that was a denial right there so that
could have been a double kill instead so
we can see down here in the lower
left-hand corner the user interface is
telling us a lot about the combat we can
see bravoteens seizing crook quests I
could want to say quests so bad crest as
they're seizing the crest spit so this
just gives you an idea as to who's
running the table who's leading the
match yeah there's a couple things going
on there too we have audio cues for
taking crests and denying crest so not
only are you seeing it in the kill feed
down there but you're also hearing as
well so we want to have multiple ways
that information is conveyed our chat
room is also observing the fact that
there are no medals which is uh yes I
really yeah I really meant to come with
a sharper eye on chap to see how they
were enjoying the fun but amidst all the
excitement I forgot to look down so hey
chat sorry about that lazy summer stone
called nu-metal really in supremacy
three hours sleep one airplane for
brains oh I didn't see that right there
i've tried guys you got that trance yeah
i just saw it and um so she talking
about the artist we should talk about
artifacts can I just saw that I did too
so um it's his Brandon writes playing
he's brought it over yeah so she's got
smile the artifact memory of a room
equipped um which highlights enemies the
ones that are low on health it
highlights red and the ones that are
full on super and highlights yellow hmm
it so you can see if somebody's about to
unleash a super you can see their charge
yeah the time you have to react is is
it's gonna look really small you get
used to it though it's it's very helpful
in making this quick knee-jerk decisions
there you go it was nice he was low on
health that many yeah that's wicked and
all good things must come to an end yeah
so if somebody has a red glow that's a
visual cue for what the community would
refer to as absolute you know
person is taking damage yeah they might
not be absolute but they'll be they'll
be closed so their health is getting
pretty low once they start in the in the
I just saw tiny glimpse of one of the
other artifacts is did you see that that
was that was old that that storm callers
not gonna be happy yeah they were just
activating the super and got got gunned
down in their prime like a storm caller
dog in the streets these matches are
really close it's full of crests it's
full of crusts again yeah so this dead
orbit shotguns doing a little bit of
work so we took a look at one of the
artifacts these new tributes to the iron
Lords the things that change the way you
play let's take a look at Dave Petty's
viewpoint and see which artifact he's
using right so he's got a memory of
Gillian so which enhances your your
tracker okay basically gives you third
eye on your primary mm-hmm so it stays
up all the time and also gives you more
granularity in the pie wedges so you
have more accurate ok screen for me wait
Toria like I into the open a shin you
can see all the ammo and the objective
show up and we'll wait for him to aim
down sights and there you go though yep
the radar stays that'll be that'll be
awfully handy now there is one artifact
where if where you can take control of
another enemies mind do we enable that
in the crucible connect yeah can I take
control of the brain of somebody who's
elsewhere on the internet and like that
you had to go out and buy nostalgia say
I all right well well I want you guys to
keep working on that technology we saw
something briefly though like a few
seconds ago before you started asking
about that where the crests actually
have physical properties in the world
look at their look Sarah Gadon cute wow
they're so yeah 18 when they get killed
they move around they you can fire a
rocket near to grenade like you'll see
it move down
ramps and it's it's not a lot it's
pretty light and we worked on it for a
long time to make sure it didn't affect
it so much as to be annoying but it's
there and it adds an extra layer of
interest to the gift I really do so Lars
Stormborn 52 just tuned in to the stream
and he wants to know if rise of iron has
private matches do you have an official
comment on that um Your Story Lauren I'm
happy to say that yes private matches
confirmed we're actually getting one
right now it does say private test build
up in the corner if that's just you know
that's our development environment but
private matches are confirmed in destiny
choose your combat mode choose your map
choose your time of day choose whether
or not you want vehicles and right now
they're enjoying a little bit of
supremacy which is our brand new game
mode which is why you see this combat
and picking up those crest you left a
hunter crest right there look what
someone just took a sorry d these games
are all right close yeah these guys
these are these are some nail biters
these are some close matches exactly
what we want and we're file we're
fighting for today is a little bit of
honor a little bit of bragging rights a
little bit of stream hype perhaps nice
so when you collect a blue crest
bluecrest is friendly quest you sort of
used the user the GI Joe laser color
palette yeah well we wanted to go simple
yeah and yeah when you when you grab a
blue one you're actually denying the
enemy team points so depriving the enemy
basically the simple thing to do
remember this mode is if you see a crust
grab it sure right right yeah no matter
the color and then you gave us different
colors for the crests so we could at
least understand how the battle is
progressing correct unlike those
grenades where you never know if you're
gonna run through an enemy fog our
friendly fun look at that super showdown
and ambers win got it you look Judy
there you go you have redeemed yourself
your team has won good games to all good
games to all
you